dans nos statistiques on a pu constater
que bon nombre de martiniquais ont déjà
été séduits par le carnaval de la guyane
mais aujourd'hui l'objectif pour moi
président du comité du tourisme de la
guyane d'être ici en anti nick c'est de
permettre effectivement avec ce produit
d'appel est d'inciter davantage de
martiniquais à se rendre en guyane
non seulement dans la période
carnavalesque mais en dehors
pourquoi parce que il faut que l'on
profite de cette opportunité que nous
donne la compagnie norvégienne d'être
sur nos routes martinique cayenne et
guadeloupe cayenne aujourd'hui grâce à
un travail qui a été initiée depuis 2007
2012 1016 pardon avec la présidente du
comité martiniquais du tourisme
c'est l'un des dossiers sur lequel les
fectivement on a travaillé et
aujourd'hui c'est une victoire
alors c'est vrai la thématique
aujourd'hui c'est le carnaval parce que
ça coïncide avec la période de la
norvégienne dans sa présence est donc de
faim fin octobre à fin mars alors
comment expliquer à des antilles et
alors que en guadeloupe ils ont par
exemple carnaval de parade qui très doux
très organisés et ont martinique est
aussi beaucoup plus dans un style de
défoulement comment expliquer aux
guadeloupéens et aux martiniquais que
cayenne pourrait proposer quelque chose
de différent pkoi d'ailleurs de
différent alors ce qui pourrait jeudi
pourrait différencier le carnaval de la
guyane au carnaval
martinique guadeloupe c'est ce fameux
temps forts du toulouse où le touloulou
effectivement 7 things emblématique dans
la guyane où nos pouvant dans deux
salles recevoir et accueillir
effectivement le touloulou il est il et
les cavaliers connaissent et la
transition c'est le touloulou qui vient
et qui invite le cavalier à danser et je
pense que c est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
antihéros tienne c'est cet engouement la
la la musique traditionnelle entraînante
et qui ma foi effectivement les ce
beaucoup sous sous cette dynamique
devenir effectivement matin le piquet
jooks et donc l'argument le piquet duke
oui et puis il faut savoir piqué alex
madeleine tout cela est possible grâce à
un norvégien mais également à cette
coopération
de plus en plus étroite avec les
autorités touristiques de martinique oui
vous savez on a il faut avoir une
volonté une volonté politique nous
l'avons eue nous nous continuons donc à
collaborer ensemble
j'en veux pour preuve on a également
travaillé sur d'autres dossiers tels que
la les produits combinés parce que pour
nous on a des voisins et c'est ensemble
que l'on pourra effectivement permettre
à ces touristes de venir et de leur
proposer un package
il faut susciter cette envie l'acte
d'achat de manière à séjourner en guyane
en martinique et voir également en
guadeloupe